[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the movie is called 80 for Brady
Sally Field
Rita Moreno
Jane Fonda Lily Tomlin
true story based on a true story about
four women in their 80s who go
cross-country to watch the Super Bowl
with Tom Brady and of course Brady makes
it a cameo appearance there Gronk is in
there
Danny Amendola Julian Edelman and uh
Sally Field of course a two-time Academy
Award winner and had a chance to talk to
her yesterday about the movie and uh I
asked her how familiar she was with Tom
Brady's accomplishments when she started
the movie
uh pretty pretty aware of them I I can't
say I'd seen every single solitary game
but I I raised three sons so
um football has always been in my life
and I then it then it became
when they left and all grew up I kind of
stuck with me as what I what I do so I
was very aware of his astonishing
achievements yeah how does this script
get to you and then what's your reaction
well it got to me from my friend Jane
Fonda she and I had been trying to work
together uh many many times over the
years and it just was never a story that
quite you know blew my skirts up as they
say
um and I like this one a lot because
it's about older women and sports it
isn't about older women looking for a
new husband or what about their kids or
you know getting their marriages to work
better or
um it really is about friendship and how
much these women love sports and I'm an
older woman and I love sports well I
wondered if it was more of a sports
movie or was it more of a girls Road
Trip movie
it's kind of both but I wouldn't call it
a normal sort of girls Road Trip movie
it's very fanciful it has a kind of uh
superhero kind of feel to it in places
um it's
you know and and a lot of in the in the
whole you know big theme of things it's
kind of about the the magic of of sports
and uh caring about something like that
when you can get so involved and it
takes you outside of your own
problems you know into the onto the
football field
your reaction when you woke up to the
news that Tom Brady was retiring was
what
feelings first of all
I I think I feel glad because I watched
him all this season and I and sometimes
he was Tom again and you know you just
were shaking your head like how is that
possible and then also I don't want him
to get hurt you know I feel like I feel
like you know wait a minute it's my boy
um I go I just didn't want him to get
crushed and crumbled into a bazillion
pieces not that he would because the
Lord knows he has been run down by those
big huge 300 pound guys before
I just didn't want to see him get hurt
at this point
um that's one and two I I wanted him to
go out in the way that he wanted to go
out and I know that that doesn't always
happen
um you you don't always get to paint the
picture you want to see but sometimes
the picture you're handed is a better
picture it just takes a little while to
stand back and go oh I see that's even
better than I could have conceived of
and
um and and third uh you know it kind of
you know in a little bit of a way uh I
wonder how it affects the movie
um and that's like way down on my chart
of things
um he was there with us last night on
the on the red carpet and he just looked
like he was enjoying how much
everybody loves him you know they so
appreciate this man's extraordinary
accomplishments and Excellence is
Excellence over any Spectrum
but were you were the women more nervous
meeting him or was he more nervous
trying to be an actor and uh you know
keeping up with you guys
I think um some of the ladies were
saying they were very nervous meeting
him I I wasn't I was the one that went
out I stood in the street as their cars
were driving up all four of them grunk
and Danny and and
um
all four I can't remember who was the
fourth one but
um and I because I knew that they were
walking in uh onto our Arena and I know
that if I were walking onto their Arena
I would I would be a wreck I would
somebody would have to give me a stiff
drink or something and so I stood out
there and waited for them all to come
and we were lived all the motorhomes
were a little bit of a cat a little bit
of a compound circle thing and I you
know welcomed him and said could I get
you a cup of coffee and here's where I
am this is where you guys are and and
I'm so glad you're here and lipstick you
know and they want let's take pictures
and I was glad I did that so I certainly
wasn't nervous
um at all
um and I don't know what they were
feeling I I think they were excited they
sure as heck didn't look nervous not not
for one moment
um not for one second did Tom look
nervous doing his scenes or being with
all of us
um and I have a little scene with Danny
and he he didn't shame it at all but you
know what being on the field doing what
they do is certainly very different than
acting I mean we get take two and they
don't but if you're on stage and
Broadway you don't get take two either
and you start as an actor you learn
where to put that the enormous amount of
adrenaline that's shooting through your
body if they would take my blood
pressure right before opening night I'm
sure I would be hospitalized because
it's off the charts and you learn how to
um maneuver through that kind of of what
your body does when it's saying you know
alert alert Dive Dive Beluga you know
harm is coming at you and but I I think
that that they know how to do that I
think they know where to put that kind
of
um stress yeah they can compartmentalize
so Danny Amendola Julian Edelman Rob
Gronkowski we're talking to someone oh
God that was the one
Julian's name went out in my head Julian
yeah and Danny and uh Gronk and uh
you know I sat and eavesdropped on their
conversation at lunch has started sat on
the edge they we had a little umbrella
umbrella table that they sat at and I
was sort of sitting on the edge I had my
little dog I was walking around and it
was great because they were reminiscing
this game
that they all played in that we that the
whole film was sort of built around this
Super Bowl and you know if to me that
was like listening to you know Katherine
Hepburn talking to Betty Davis you know
about what about that night that we it
was
so
fun and amazing to hear these
extraordinary athletes talking about
that one time and those things and
you're laughing and and Tom trying to
talk Danny into coming back and you know
would you do that too Sally if you got
together with Tom Hanks would you talk
about Forrest Gump or would you yes okay
yes and we we would do that especially
because there's enough time since Forest
that we would talk you remember that
time when I saw you at the coffee shop
and you were with and we went and then
you know
yes and that's what I mean it was like
eavesdropping on something that seemed
so
um not really run in the mail because it
was a special game but you know they've
they've put that in their whole long
list of achievements uh would be like us
talking about you know Tom and I talking
about the two films that we had done
together remember the first time we met
remember that thing
um and if they were listening they would
think wow
um but as I listened to them I realized
they were just it was you know
just another thing in a way
did uh I heard Jane Fonda flirted a
little bit
oh Jane fond is always flirting
no I'm just really sort of not that kind
of a flirt I mean I probably flirt
without knowing I'm flirting
um I mean maybe someone could say
because I was out there welcoming
offering him a cup of coffee they could
have said that was flirting it didn't
feel like flirting I actually honestly I
I added this to my character because she
says this I I really don't know what is
flirting I'm really not sure what it is
because I kind of got you know ripped
off the streets from my high school
practically and thrown into
um you know being a celebrity that I
really I don't know that I really know
what flirting is
what do people say to you on the street
what do they bring up movie role or a
line from a movie is there one in
particular
years especially recently
um
I just sort of shake my head of all the
people who mention the Flying Nun and I
think how do you even know about it I
mean the people that are saying that are
like in their you know early 30s I think
oh wow that was nice
and nice on these various you know
places I I you know where they show old
television stuff I I have no idea but
then a lot of people say other things
you know notice something more recent or
you know or forest or Mrs Doubtfire or
Steel Magnolias gets mentioned a lot
with you know drink your juice Shelby I
didn't know what love was back in the
mid 60s but I had I had a crush on you
as as uh The Flying Nun so you might I
think Julie Andrews was my first crush
Sally but you might have been second you
might have been second I think I think
the sound of music uh she she got me
there I was young but yeah she got me
there too but I was available she just
she didn't know that uh I guess with Tom
now retired uh is there a sequel
oh gosh I don't know if there is they
better hurry up
well uh it's great to talk to you
congratulations on this and uh I know
the timing you didn't plan on it but you
know with Tom retiring and now this
movie coming out yeah uh yeah hopefully
uh you'll get you'll get a lot of great
responses from it but thank you again
for uh for joining us
Sally Field hey I took my shot took a
shot yeah I respect that I want to let
her know I had a crush on her